what do you have planned for this coming
year I know that are you recording right
now yeah I may I'm actually making an
album and a lot of the songs came from
those in between sleep sleep times okay
oddly enough and um and I'm gonna go on
tour in Europe this summer which is
always a joy to play music live and
really just doing this podcast and
trying to hang out with people and in
front of microphones the podcast is Nora
Jones is playing along and it's a
terrific Mavis Staples yeah was on the
podcast she was at Mark rubby a do you
know he's incredible I'm not as familiar
with him no yeah um uh we had Bobby Hall
aka the rapper Logic yep um which was a
really fun like meeting of two different
worlds yeah you know so yeah it's it
kind of runs the gamut it's there's no
limitations it just has to be playing
music together there's no genre or
anything also I will tell you this as a
fan of your podcast uh you have an
amazing obviously you have an amazing
singing voice but I love your speaking
voice really yeah it sounds it sounds
very uh it just sounds really lovely
that was the thing I was most nervous
about it well you know well when you
hear yourself
speaking recorded is the most annoying
thing on the planet to most people and
I'm no different so when I hear myself
saying I can I can get with that I'm
used to that but when I hear myself talk
sometimes I'm just like ugh I think
that's healthy I think it's normal I
think when if you're someone who
when you hear yourself says yeah
more of this something's wrong I am uh I
am horrified uh when I hear myself
speaking but uh then I just say yeah
that's just self-hate and it's probably
done you some good it's done yeah it's
done good and also I one thing I did
notice listening back and approving
stuff is I have a weird cackle because
when Sarah and I get to laughing
sometimes my co-host or whenever me and
one of the guests after the song is done
there's always like this crazy laughter
because we're trying a song for the
first time and then we just bust out
laughing when it's done but I have the
my laugh surprised the hell out of me I
didn't know I had a cackle right you
know uh yeah occasionally you discover
things about yourself yes I don't know
if you enjoyed listening to yourself uh
I I don't really listen to the podcast
well you've got these twins you're busy
now well also if I didn't I mean I
didn't always have the twins even before
I I didn't like it's not you have to go
overboard and say even when I had
nothing to do I literally had nothing to
do if someone pressed play and put like
headphones on me I would just take them
oh no I really I don't uh you're not a
consumer of you know the dealer
shouldn't consume his own yeah that's
that's an old saying it would be called
podcaster baiting if you yeah
God we've got to clean up this Nora
Jones podcast I never thought I'd be
saying that I love it I I wish they
could take credit Sarah came up with
that when she was really fast
you know you mentioned earlier like well
I wouldn't have never have a chance to
have a meal with you I'd be delighted to
anytime if you're going to be in town
and you need someone to grab you know
breakfast whatever I will you'll pick it
up and bring it to my hotel breakfast
we're not quite dinner yet
I will take you up from meal between 7
A.M and 8 30 a.m yeah and then we split
it it's got to be an International House
of Pancakes yeah
obviously I any time I would just be
delighted I would be ecstatic oh thank
you so much we brought it full circle
you are a podcaster and I a pod
masturbator podcast Norah Jones is an
honoration
yeah he really just went for it yeah I
think what I'm talking about is
different than what you're talking about
it's been another filthy show Norah
Jones
Nora thank
you thank you great to see you all